sifu is a demanding game that requires
you to master the art of kung fu on your
quest for revenge and you'll want to
come prepared with as much knowledge as
possible in this beginner's guide we've
got you covered with 12 tips and tricks
to help you become the ultimate pacmay
master
there are certain attacks you can
unleash that temporarily leave you
invulnerable to other opponents while
the animation plays out these are known
as invulnerability frames or iframes and
you'll want to take full advantage of
them one of the most common moves that
fall into this category are the
takedowns which occur when you break an
enemy's structure this move not only
instantly eliminates your opponent most
of the time but it's also an effective
way to avoid getting hit by someone else
and just like the takedowns holding the
circle or b button on a downed enemy
will also temporarily give you iframes
so you can use the few seconds you have
someone downed to your advantage
it's easy to want to button mash and
sifu especially at the start but we
recommend going into the pause menu to
see what combos you have at your
disposal some of them like the square
and x directional throw can be
invaluable during combat as you can use
it to toss your enemies into others for
some space control inflict wall damage
and more however you might not know it
if you fail to check out the list of
combos keep an eye on additional combos
you can unlock from the skill tree as
well
here's an example combo that makes use
of the sweep follow-up and finding a
second opportunity to use it as it is
guaranteed after a focus attack
[Music]
you can engage with most enemies by
simply pummeling them if you try you'll
be blocked parried and dodged especially
in the later levels where you're likely
to be a bit older and taking a lot more
damage instead learn to combine your
attacks with a strong defense for better
results more specifically the standing
dodge holding lb and timing a
directional input against an enemy will
not only help you avoid damage but will
leave you close enough for an optimal
punish you can also periodically tap the
block button followed by an attack to
parry an opponent even if the timing of
your attack isn't enough to pull off the
parry blocking an opponent raises their
structure which is equally as important
as depleting their health
speaking of which let's talk about the
structure system because it's something
that could easily be overlooked each
time you block an attack a bar on the
bottom of your screen raises this is the
structure bar and if it fills up to the
max you'll be temporarily stunned
leaving you open for devastating attacks
you can think of it like your guard
meter or armor where it can be broken
and then you're left with your red life
or health to combat with until it
regenerates some of your stronger foes
or enemies with weapons can do both
structure and health damage to you so be
careful of them enemies have a structure
meter too and even if you block or parry
their attacks it will fill use this to
your advantage especially on a foe who's
hard to hit with these opponents it's
best to block their attacks fill their
structure meter and then unleash a
deadly strike of your own if spot
dodging isn't an option
[Music]
on the topic of structure we recommend
always keeping your structure meter as
low as possible one thing you can do is
back away during the fight and as long
as you don't sprint or attack your
structure meter will go down use the
environment as cover to regain your
structure too
nearly every level that has group fights
also have interactable items for you to
use against your enemies when you have
the environmentalist skill unlocked this
can be a huge help to get enemies off of
you quickly and is faster to activate
than picking up a weapon manually such
as a bottle or a bat levels like the
museum have a lot of unique items at
your disposal when you have this skill
and tends to make the stages feel a
little bit more immersive
although sifu is a kung fu game that
focuses on hand-to-hand combat you can
also use weapons and the previously
mentioned environmental objects these
are items such as swords staves bats
pipes and sticks that are littered
throughout each stage the thing is you
can frequently begin mini encounters
with a weapon if you play it smart you
can go back to an earlier area to
retrieve a metal bat before heading to
the next section or look around the room
you're in to make sure you've collected
a pipe that will help you with the
battle ahead
you can even take weapons into boss
fights however keep in mind that weapons
do break but there are things you can do
to maximize their durability
each level contains a handful of shrines
which are represented by little green
dragon statues these shrines contain
stat boosts such as increased structure
more focus bars and even the ability to
earn more focus after a successful dodge
or parry however certain boosts are
locked to specific age ranges one of
which is a reward that grants additional
weapon durability this can only be used
if your sifu is 25 or younger so make
sure to maximize this category first and
build according to your age moving
forward
and speaking of unlockable abilities we
recommend revisiting levels after you're
comfortable with the game's combat with
the earlier levels especially you can
make your way through while raising your
combo meter as much as possible do this
until you have enough xp to permanently
unlock an ability from the skill tree
remember you must acquire a move a
certain number of times before it's
permanently unlocked for instance the
charged backfist move costs a thousand
xp to unlock once but costs an
additional 5000 xp which is 1000 xp five
times to unlock permanently
as you play through sifu you'll discover
keys that lead to shortcuts within that
level or even previous levels all levels
feature a shortcut that lets you quickly
get to the boss from an early section in
that stage so we recommend replaying a
level right away to finish it with a
lower age counter
while your main priority should be to
master the fundamentals of the game
focus is an ability that allows you to
slow down time to unleash an unblockable
attack which also gives you iframes
focus attacks are crucial as they deal
damage and cause enemies to be stunned
for a moment after the attack
in the bottom right of the screen is
your focus meter and it can be filled by
successfully evading and parrying
attacks you can actually give yourself
more focus bars by upgrading this
ability at shrines though we don't
recommend solely relying on these
abilities a firm mastery of the basic
combos and mechanics will serve you far
better in the long run
now this is a tip i only recommend if
you're truly struggling to finish a
level given it's a bit annoying to do
repeatedly each time you die sifu
instantly creates a save meaning you
can't undo the death that just occurred
however there is a workaround you can
use and it involves using cloud saves
before a tricky boss or enemy upload
your save to the cloud then if you die
or if the fight doesn't go as smoothly
as you might have hoped simply close the
game and download the save from the
cloud placing you back at the start of
the fight
got any other tips let me know in the
comments and if any of these tips were
useful to you drop us a like and a
subscribe and tune into gamespot for
even more seafood coverage
[Music]